and the reason why I care so much about
this is that if we talk about the notion
that there are principalities or they're
they're like there are agencies which
are above the human consciousness or
that gather human consciousnesses
together and gather phenomena together
let's say then the idea that it's only
either
from heaven or hell that it's only good
or bad is not the one we experience we
experience Agency on us that doesn't
necessarily have those two polarities
and so the problem is
if we experience that then how do we
account for it in in in our own symbolic
structure how can we talk about it
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
so hello everybody this is the return of
Richard Roland we haven't done this in a
while uh Universal History Richard has
been super busy right you've been you've
been traveling a lot I've been busy too
we've all been pretty busy and so but
it's all for exciting things and uh and
we're gonna see some uh we were just
talking about the golden key which is a
book that Richard has been bringing up
once in a while that he's working on now
I wrote a piece for and we're going to
move on move forward with bringing that
out you know Richard is right now
publishing all his fantasy stuff he he
started he started posting that and so
we'll put a link to that in the
description there's just so many amazing
things going on so uh so Richard thanks
for thanks for despite everything coming
along well I'm very glad to be here and
the extra like uh the back story that
people out there don't know is this is
like the third time that we've actually
tried to get together and record this
episode and one time we just ended up
needing to work on some other stuff and
another time I scheduled it on American
Thanksgiving not realizing that it was
American Thanksgiving and so uh I was at
church and you messaged me and you're
like hey are we talking today wait it's
Thanksgiving you're probably I was
realizing it in in like real time yeah
sitting there in the zoom yeah but we're
here now and I'm very excited because I
get to talk about uh stuff that I
actually know things about
um which is always fun uh so we're going
to talk about the Anglo-Saxons today
um and as many people know I'm a
dramatic philologist that's really you
could say that's what like my door into
medieval studies uh you know I've always
been interested in the Middle Middle
Ages but even as a kid but um
my real door into medieval studies as a
as a scholar was through Germanic
philology and specifically Anglo-Saxon
and Old Norse literature and languages
and
um so we're going to start by talking
about
um it'd probably be the first of a
couple of conversations about the old
north
um and Universal history and the way
that the
the way that the Christians of the late
Germanic Iron Age uh which is this the
Germanic Iron Age is a period some
people well there are different dates
assigned to it but I think most people
have it from about 500 BC maybe a little
bit later uh up to 800 A.D so the late
Germanic Iron Age this is the period in
which the um
uh this and Beyond is the period in
which the various uh Northern Germanic
peoples begin to convert to Christianity
um and um it's the basically it's the
period immediately before the Viking age
so we will get into some Viking age
stuff as well so probably not today but
in the future
um so what I wanted to talk about was
um actually let's just pick up again
with the uh the the uh Chronicle uh or
The Apocalypse of pseudo Methodius it
seems like this is a text that we just
come back to constantly over and over
again and it really is a central text to
the way that these cultures understood
Universal history and one of the
important things
to note about this text and something
we've brought up a couple of times
before is that in the Apocalypse of
pseudomothodius we find a witness of
this tradition
that there was a fourth son of Noah
now I think that in The Apocalypse of
pseudo Methodius he's named something
like uh uh yonatus or uh I think that's
right
and he would be born After the flood is
that the idea
or yoniton or yonotus oh okay so that's
I mean that's the question that's
actually the big spicy question about
him and this goes back to The Apocalypse
of pseudom Methodius is relying for this
on a much earlier Syriac work called the
cave of treasures in case anybody's
wondering and there's a pretty good I
think Sebastian Brock did a pretty good
translation of that so you can go read
that it's got just like a bunch of the
early Syrian uh Slash you know the early
Christian slash late Jewish Traditions
that were preserved in Syria and
um concerning like Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden and all this stuff and if
you wanted to if you wanted to get like
a better
um
a framework for reading data from the
Syria and that's a pretty good it's a
pretty good place to start but um yeah
so this is the question where when was
he born where was he born
um some uh ancient authors and medieval
authors have him being born on the ark
others have him being born after the art
because uh the Genesis text is actually
fairly explicit about who exited the ark
right and so it's this so then it's like
well but you know maybe he's a little
baby so uh just just in case people
don't know there is a strong tradition
that
um uh in in a lot of ancient texts
especially in Syrian
uh that when so Noah has these three
sons and then when God tells him that
he's going to destroy the Earth with a
flood Noah lives uh as celibate until
the flood oh really interesting yeah
this is this is pretty well attested
tradition okay so so the idea is that he
lives a celibate until the flood
and then on the ark with his wife he
conceives this fourth son
and he's either born of the ark or he's
born after they disembark
um kind of depending I mean the sort of
like the the math if he's born if he's
conceived on the ark the math doesn't
really work for him to have been born on
there necessarily but you know these are
this is long ago and far off time so you
know uh mathematical considerations not
the most important thing and also people
lived 900 years so yeah yeah who knows
how long it took for a child right
exactly yeah yeah so um so yeah and and
you could think about the symbolism of
that in itself the idea that Noah lived
as celibate when he was building the ark
yeah but then he conceives uh a son
while he's on the ark and while the
flood waters are covering the Earth yeah
and also it I mean especially if you
understand the ark as the seed for the
new world then it all kind of makes
sense and if you understand the ark as
an image almost like of a
of the a holy place you know in chaos
you know there's all these there's
different types the ark has all kinds of
associations but that those associations
are definitely there you see some
medieval representations of the Ark as a
seed if you've ever seen it looks like
uh it's like kind of like not a sort of
almond shaped like an almond shaped yeah
so yeah so I mean and I mean there's
some weird stuff too uh about this
trying to decide how weird we want to go
for for our return to Universal history
so I mean world is competing with you
for weirdness right now there's you know
what it's a very you're right that's a
very good point so there's this very
ancient association between flooding and
menstruation yeah
um which you know if you've met red
Matthew's book uh is very it's very easy
to understand it makes sense but they're
also like certain taboos about
reproduction uh during during
menstruation like that the point of all
of this is the fact that this fourth son
uh may have been conceived on the ark
yeah but it's important to understand
like I know this is we're getting into
really weird territory here but it's
okay but we also let's say New
Beginnings are born out of exceptional
things and yeah that's that's what I'm
trying to get to and you can even like
see this in the way like they're sending
the Raven out sending the dove out the
sea the branch all that stuff right it's
new life being born out of this like
really exceptional kind of a space and
and so this fourth son of Noah who in uh
Greek and Syrian text is usually like
yonton or yoniton or uh yonitos in I
think in Latin although I think there's
also a Georgian version that's like bony
tour or something like that but anyway
this character character this figure of
the fourth son the point is that he's
born out of this kind of weird liminal
marginal space right you know and he he
functions in that way in more than one
way for instance uh first of all he you
know isn't actually in the canonical
text of scripture right this is uh I
wouldn't say it's a minority tradition
it's an obscure tradition today but
everyone in the Middle Ages knew about
this but um but it's definitely it's
definitely an apocryphal tradition right
uh in the sense of you know apocryphal
being something that's hidden right and
and uh if people don't remember in The
Apocalypse of pseudo Methodius the role
that he has is that he goes off far to
the east which seems like the wrong
direction for the stuff we're going to
be talking about today but he goes off
forward to these to the land to the Land
of the Rising Sun uh is actually what it
says and there he is taught sort of
esoteric wisdom from God and uh
eventually like Nimrod goes off and
travels and uh he's uh he's the one that
Nimrod learns like divination and
astronomy and things like this from
Nimrod learns this from yongtong yeah in
the in the in the like the Cave of
Wonders like in the Syrian text yeah and
um and of course this is problematic
because Nimrod also introduces the the
worship of fire
um right he finds this fire ascending
from the earth like so the light coming
from below is opposed to the light
coming from above and he goes down to
where the light is coming from and he uh
a voice speaks to him out of the fire
and he worships it and this is like a
sort of like a Syrian you know there's a
bit of like a polemic against their
Persian neighbors here right uh the
Zoroastrianism of the worship of fire
but anyway So eventually yonton tells
him you know don't come back you know
teaches them some some stuff but then he
kind of sees the direction Nimrod is
heading and he tells him don't come back
so anyway he's this interesting figure
and he's really Associated you know back
when we were talking about India in the
Far East he's Associated ultimately with
the idea of like the Easter of Eastern
wisdom the Eastern philosopher the
gymnosophist all that stuff goes back to
goes back to this this fourth set of
Noah
so the weird thing is that there is
actually there are a large number of
connections which we are really just
coming to understand when I say we I
mean like the the scholarly community at
large people who study uh Old English
culture uh uh Germanic studies Etc there
are a large number of connections
between what you could call the Old
Testament pseudo epigrapha like the
legit Apocrypha when I say Apocrypha I
don't mean like Tobit or Maccabees or
Judith or something like that that's
just the director's cut of the Bible
um but when I so when I say Apocrypha I
mean like really apocryphal stuff like
uh
um you know the Book of Enoch The Book
of Enoch is a good example yeah or the
life unless you're Ethiopian obviously
but
um uh The Book of Enoch the life of Adam
and Eve stuff like that so there is a
huge connection between this apocryphal
literature
uh the Syrian tradition uh which was
probably the the means of conveyance for
a lot of these things
and Anglo-Saxon Christianity
which is again a very surprising kind of
a thing and I think that's part of why
it's taken us so long to notice
um because in the past traditionally uh
Academia has been very siled so if you
are somebody studying Syriac or
Ethiopian you were probably not all
somebody who was also studying you know
Beowulf yeah yeah but the nestorians
appear in the Middle Ages in the kind of
weird tales as these yeah as these kind
of mystical yeah so similar to the way
the gymnosophists appeared yeah yeah but
this is even before that this connection
comes back even before that and
um in this case we actually have a a
name a face a date that we can probably
Peg the connection to
um so it comes through a couple of of
routes one is that there was a huge
treasury of these pseudopigraphal texts
usually translated first into Latin and
then into Old Irish that were kept in
these Irish monasteries and so people
who know the story of the conversion of
the Anglo-Saxons it really happened from
two directions there was a a Roman uh
push for conversion kind of from the
south and then at the same time there
was a an Irish push for conversion from
the north and eventually the two sort of
met in the middle and they had some
synods and you know it's a whole it's a
whole thing but these Irish monasteries
uh unfortunately most of the manuscripts
they had were destroyed by Vikings
during the Viking age but
these Irish monasteries had
um extensive collections of these pseudo
epigraphal texts for instance
there is a an old Irish
um it's called the Saltair narain
probably said that wrong uh because it's
old Irish but um and and and uh my my
brain does not do Gaelic languages so
anyway all the all the all the Gaelic
like the old the old Irish speakers out
there you have to just forgive me it's
your Anglo-Saxon you know yeah man you
can't do it can't do it yeah but the
Saltair no rain uh or which literally
just means like the psalter of the
quatraines
um is a collection of about a hundred I
think it's exactly no it's 150 because
it's a Salter so it's got 150 poems in
it
um it's a collection of of uh 150 Psalms
or you know quatrains you know these
poems that that have like these the
basic stings that is four lines right
and basically it's the entire old Irish
Universal history of the world starting
with Adam and Eve and the creation of
the world and going forward through time
and if you go read the Sultana rain what
they basically do is they take all of
this all of the pseudopigraphal stuff
and they take the early chapters of
Genesis and they take you know the rest
of the historical books of the
scriptures and the gospels and all these
things and they just weave it together
into a cohesive account and I just want
to emphasize this was a book that was
made for Lay people it's not written in
Latin It Was Written in Old Irish
because the point of it was uh that it
would be easy way to sort of teach
people the
I don't want to say teach people their
Bible but teach people the tradition
like teach people like pass on pass on
what do we as Christians believe about
um where we came from the origins of
humanity where did demons and angels and
fairies and all the stuff and so you can
go look at this and I don't think the
whole thing
has been translated into English but
good bits of it have there might be
there might be a a a a whole translation
in English that's like really archaic I
think maybe back in the 1800s but
um they do give the origin of fairies in
there
I mean yes I mean where where fairies
are uh you're gonna get me off on a on a
thing here um sorry yeah no it's okay I
mean it's just so interesting yeah um
well actually I was at uh I was at
doxicon in October November and uh there
was some symbolic World folks there
which is great we got a picture together
and uh it's great to see you all but
adoxicon somebody gave this beautiful uh
talk and it was just on you know 19th
century first-hand accounts of people
who met fairies and the fairies were
asking will can we be saved right that
was the question and uh the the the
general consensus in all of these
stories seems to sort of be that's a
question that cannot be known until the
day of judgment but anyway yeah like you
start getting to the fairy thing it's
really interesting but basically in the
Middle Ages there are two or three main
theories of where what fairies are and
where they come from and the you know
the first one of those and this is also
found in rabbinic literature is that
they are the unwashed children of Eve
you you know this idea that God or the
Archangel Michael depending on the story
comes to bless Eve and her children as
after the fall and
um Eve uh puts her uh uh but but it's
like it's like washing day and not all
the kids are clean right and so she puts
the dirty ones behind her back and they
don't get the blessing
um and so the ones that are blessed are
the ones from which humanity is ascended
and the ones that didn't get the
blessing they're the ones that fairies
are descended from so they're sort of
like kind of like well fairies and gin
and like you know all the all the you
know these different yeah these
intermediary ambiguous kind of spirits
so that's one Theory another theory and
I think this is the one that you find in
the Saltair in the rain is that fairies
are the descendants of angels who took a
neutral stance during the war in heaven
so during the work oh really oh you
didn't know this so this is what I've
been wondering about if that exists if
there was again okay a gin tradition in
Christianity
neutral space or ambiguous space yeah so
so this is is probably in the Middle
Ages it's probably the most common
theory for where fairies come from so
the basic idea is that they were Angels
who took took a neutral position in the
war in heaven and they didn't fight
against uh Lucifer but they also didn't
fight on the side of God so they're
they're cast out but they're not cast
all the way down so whereas Lucifer the
devil and his angels they're cast down
to Hell these guys are cast sort of
halfway down to earth and they become
these sort of like very earthy spirits
and and this is like this these spirits
of their these in between spirits of the
air like they're right there are these
in between spirits of the air and so
then this is why there's this big
question in like sort of Irish folklore
of can they be saved because they
weren't like totally damned right so
then now this is almost very similar to
The Gin
it's more or less exactly the same and I
think that I think that that ties back
to a much older uh kind of
organizational source for both of those
Traditions yeah um and by the way I'll
just put a like a little plug uh you
won't actually get it in this book but
you'll find it in the next one that's
going to come out this next year
um in my own sort of fantasy legendarium
this is the origin that I use for
they're not called fairies in the story
but the essentially the fairies that the
main culture the embodian culture in my
fantasy story they're descended from but
one of the things that I try to sort of
suss out in my own reworking of that
myth is well why did they take this
neutral position and try to answer that
question so if you want my personal take
on that you can read sometime next year
and then it comes out yeah that book
will come out but anyway so then the
third the third theory of kind of where
fairies come from is essentially that
they're the Nephilim
oh directly now yeah and and so with the
Nephilim understood as as either the
descendants of Cain or the descendants
of the sons of God Daughters of men it
just depends on like how do you read
that sons of God Daughters of anything
even in the Syriac sources like for
instance saying Ephraim uh is a very
early witness to like that sort of
cephite hypothesis
um and whereas there are other other you
know or very early texts such as the
Book of Enoch which have it which have
it as you know this coupling of angels
and humans and we've talked before about
why these are not really uh and in the
Middle Ages especially by the authors of
things like the Beowulf poem these are
not necessarily viewed as mutually
exclusive positions because well for one
thing
either way either way that you read it
there's a there's this Unholy pairing at
these you know uh movement down the
mountain at these levels of the
ontological hierarchy and the line of
Cain is always involved somehow either
the light and with Father Stephen
deyoung's uh kind of exposition ritual
aspect of it then those two actually can
completely coexist and there's no issue
at all right so for me it's not people
are like oh but doesn't this person say
this and doesn't this person say this
and um you know it's
since we're just doing tangents today so
there's a little bit uh for for for some
other studies that I've been doing I've
been reading a lot of Saint Cyril of
Alexandria lately and um he has a um he
has this wonderful
wonderful sort of polemic piece called
uh against Julian right so this is a
piece that he writes against Julie in
the apostate and one of the things that
he does is he excerpts uh significant
portions of Julian the apostates against
the galileans which is his his sort of
tirade against Christianity and um and
it's really the I think it's the only
extant place that we actually have that
now is excerpted within Saint Cyril but
in uh in Julian's writings he he's
giving all of these arguments against
the Virgin birth which he finds I mean
Julian is I don't I don't know how to
say this nicely
um you don't have to say anything nice
about Julian the apostate well no that's
not here here's the thing Julian has
like a bunch of very Protestant
objections to Christianity like and
again I'm not trying to like at my
Protestant friends or family or whatever
but like gilding the apostate if you if
you read his actual complaints like
Chris against Christianity he can't
stand the fact that we're kissing relics
he can't stand the fact that we think
the Eucharist is the body and blood of
Christ he can't stand the fact that we
call Mary the theotokos this is
literally this is one of his main
arguments against Christianity is he
says it's insane to call a human woman
the mother of God you can't do that
right so he's actually like a an early
witness to a couple of things one is
that at this very early stage theotokos
was a title everybody had already been
using for a long time
but one of the arguments he makes
against calling Mary the theotokos is he
says okay okay okay if you really
believe it went down this way then that
makes Jesus one of the Nephilim right
right which is wrong and not the point
just to be clear but it's also an early
witness to the fact that Julian who we
have to remember basically went to
Seminary with the cappadocian fathers or
he went to the academy in Athens with
Saint Basil the great and Gregory the
Theologian right and this was his
understanding in other words this is how
he'd been taught the scriptures was that
this is how to read Genesis chapter
chapter all that to say uh I don't
really see these things as being sort of
mutually exclusive at least on a
symbolic level right you have kind of
the same thing happening either way
what's really important is that you have
this lineage of monsters descendants
right uh so yeah in either version of
the story the line of Cain is the
daughters of men in that equation and
the result of that Unholy pairing is
this race of monsters yeah and uh so
that this so this is the third version
that you find in the Middle Ages of sort
of like Origins for like where do
fairies come from and by fairies I mean
Giants monsters Etc so
um and this is this is for instance the
uh the version that you find in Beowulf
which we'll talk about a little more in
a minute so
um but in this case uh uh so to kind of
rewind all the way back there's this
there's this very strong witness to the
Old Testament pseudo epigrapha in the
Syrian tradition within Anglo-Saxon
literature and it's only just now
starting to be better understood but
most of this probably goes back to a guy
named Saint Theodore of Tarsus do you
know about Saint Theodore tarzas he's
one of the earliest archbishops of
Canterbury he was Archbishop starting in
668. so this is very shortly after the
Anglo-Saxon conversion and
um he was born
in Tarsus he grew up in Constantinople
he visited Odessa he spoke and read
Syrian fluently
and by sort of a series of of historical
uh accidents whatever you want to call
it he first goes west to Rome where he
lives at an Eastern Monastery in Rome
and
um at this time uh he this is when he
learns Latin and then after the Senate
of Whitby is held in 664.
he is sent to Canterbury because they
need a new Archbishop and so they sent
him there and he goes there and there
are sort of stories of his erecting what
is either the first rude screen or just
an icono Stace
in a church there in in England and um
you know all this stuff so he's a really
interesting figure and uh if you look at
him I mean he was totally steeped in the
Byzantine theological tradition
completely steeped in a Syrian
theological tradition kind of kind of
somebody who went to every great Center
of Christianity in the in the East
except for maybe Northern Africa and was
able to acquire the learning acquire the
languages and so he brings with him and
at Canterbury he founds a school called
the school of Canterbury and there's
lots of evidence to suggest if you kind
of look at the Chronicles and also the
list of books so sometimes we don't have
surviving books but we have surviving
book lists yeah from the school of
Canterbury we see uh that things like
the The Apocalypse of pseudo Methodius
are listed among books that they had
access to so they were definitely aware
of these Traditions there's a really
great book which I have just over there
but the spine is facing away from me so
I can't see the name of it right now but
it's something like the Apocrypha in the
Anglo-Saxon homologic tradition
something like that
and basically it does a great job of
looking at sermons books of homilies so
in the Middle Ages people were not
typically expected especially when you
had varying levels of learning and
sometimes your village priest wasn't you
know maybe the most articulate guy
that's fine we just need him to do the
Liturgy right but
um because you had these varying levels
of learning in the Middle Ages it was
not necessarily expected that your
priest would always just be able to give
like a banger of a homily yeah you know
off the top of his head every Sunday
morning or something like this and so
it's very common to have books of
homilies these are called These are
called homilarities and these homilies
would be arranged based on the
liturgical year and the the lectionary
readings and things like this so they're
really they were copied a lot which
means they're more likely to survive and
also they are really important Witnesses
so we can look at them to figure out
things like well we know that the
absolute latest date that this Feast
started being celebrated in this region
was you know in this Century it could
have been before that that but it
certainly you know certainly was after
that yeah yeah and so
uh or absolutely early State anyway
all that to say so the really important
uh really important Witnesses for lots
of different things and I'm really
interested in them a for the actual
content which is which is usually pretty
awesome you know and and then B because
they are a good gauge of what is being
taught to lay people right and so it's
like one thing to say that this this
stuff is uh present in a you know it's
it's a library it's somewhere where
monks have access to it Etc said okay
but what what did the average
Anglo-Saxon peasant common or whatever
what did they think about the world and
if you go look at the homilies you can
just see hear the things that are being
taught and so if you if you start
looking through the Anglo-Saxon
homolytic tradition you find all kinds
of wonderful things
um and one of the things that you find
is that they were taking the Old
Testament pseudopigrapha
for instance the life of Adam and Eve
the Vizio poly the vision of Saint Paul
or The Apocalypse of Saint Paul is
sometimes called
um the life of Peter and Paul like all
these other important kind of apocryphal
or pseudopigraphal works and they were
actually incorporating them into their
homilies to lay people to help them
understand things about the afterlife I
mean the Visio Pali is one of the
earliest
no we put it this way there's no Dante's
Inferno without the Visio poly right
it's one of the earliest descriptions
that we have
um although it it probably relies on
like the the Ezra Literature Like the uh
you know second and third Ezra and
things like that but it's one of the
earliest Witnesses we have to kind of
this tradition of like the torments of
hell and this idea let the punishment
fit the crime stuff like that
um
one of my favorite things uh in there
and I think this is in third Ezra as
well is the idea that Herod is forever
imprisoned in Hell sitting on a burning
Throne
um and so it's you know it's one because
he misused his kinship but there's also
kind of a subtext there that sort of
suggests a a uh how do I say this
delicately a connection between that and
childbirth because of all the children
that he killed and so
um you know things like this
um anyway it's it's pretty it's all
pretty Grim stuff but very interesting
reading
um it's also important for English
accent studies because it's actually uh
quoted and in some places in paraphrase
and others in the Beowulf poem when they
tried to describe the marsh where
Grendel's mother lives which is this
very I mean it's uh it's it's literally
it's hell right this place where these
monsters live this you know kind of
haunted swamp or mirror they go back and
they use a bunch of this stuff from
these homilies that are normally
descriptions of the torments of hell and
they use it to describe this location
um and so there's there's other stuff in
there
um deliberate connections uh throughout
Beowulf between sigurd right the Slayer
of the um
and I want to say is it cigarette or
Sigma now I think it's Sigmund because
when the Beowulf poet wrote his poem
Sigmund was the famous Dragon Slayer and
then later on it's a sun cigarette um I
might have that I think that's right uh
but basically they take the most famous
Germanic Dragon Slayer and then use
language from his story and then they
take language from the story of Saint
Michael casting Satan out of heaven and
language from his story and they
incorporate both of that into the story
of Beowulf killing monsters and so it's
like let's tie our hero who is a hero
set in pre-christian times but it's a
story being put together by a Christian
and so let's take the most famous Pagan
Dragon Slayer and the most famous
Christian Dragonslayer you could say and
incorporate them both into our heroes so
this is to me this is what makes the
Beowulf poem so interesting is the way
that it
um you know it's it's certainly compiled
by or or written by a Christian probably
a monk probably in the early 700s at
some point we'll talk more about Beowulf
but
um but what that Monk Is he's taking
these older stories not just from like
Germanic paganism but also from the sort
of biblical Apocrypha like the
apocryphan tradition you're taking both
of those stories and integrated them so
in the Beowulf poem for instance you get
this idea
of Sheaf or shayoff or shayafa depending
on how you want to say his name and
where you're from back then and this
character
um although this gets a little
complicated because the Beowulf poet who
is our earliest witness like earliest
written witness to this character he
actually combines him with an old Pagan
character so we've got this tradition of
a fourth son of Noah there's also this
tradition of a guy named Shield which
literally just means Shield who is the
lead the mythical progenitor of the
Danish Kings
um he's he's the Danish equivalent of
like King Arthur and the Beowulf poet
takes those two characters and he
combines them into a single character
called Shield shaving right a shield son
of Chief is what that literally means
but the the the chief myth or the chief
Legend
um is about this young boy
uh who washes up on the shores of
Western Europe
um back Far Far away long ago in The
Mists of Time watches up on the shores
of Northern Europe and uh he's shining
he's beautiful he's his skin is
literally glowing oh which is by the way
how Noah is described when he's born in
like third Enoch
um and uh he's
um there's nobody with him he just
washes up on shore and he's lying in the
boat
and he's got his head resting on a Sheaf
of wheat which is why he's called Sheaf
and uh the people take him and they take
him back up to the hall and their King
has recently died
and they don't have a new king and so
they take this boy and they make him
King and he basically brings he's a
culture hero he brings uh was what is
19th century uh Scholars refer to this
kind of figure as a corn King right
somebody who brings the secrets of
Agriculture and how to how to grow crops
and things like that he brings them to
the Scandinavian people so he's this
weird legendary figure that's on a
certain level like well attested but at
the same time not where we don't really
know much about him
and what seems to be happening uh
specifically during the time of Alfred
the Great is that they take sheave which
is probably this pre-existing sort of
Germanic Legend
um which nobody really knows when it
started or where it started or how to
explain it they take sheave and you'll
find this for instance in the
Anglo-Saxon Chronicle which is written
during Alfred's life of Alfred for
people who don't know Alpha the great
um in addition to making the Danes
behave themselves Alfred the Great uh
oversaw a tremendous uh program of you
could say like literary renewal and
Revival in uh Anglo-Saxon England and
he's responsible for just a tremendous
amount of of most of the best
Anglo-Saxon literature comes from
um was at least preserved written down
preserved collected Etc by Scholars
working for him he also did a quite a
bit of translation himself he he
translated Saint Gregory the Great's
pastoral care
and then he also translated the Bowie
thesis the constellation of philosophy
although uh when I say you translated he
translated it the way people translated
things in the Middle Ages which which is
as you're translating if you think of a
way to improve this well just go right
ahead you know
um and and actually yeah kind of like
Alfred's better
um
uh well okay so here's the thing about
Alfred's boethius is that um
a lot of people say oh well Alfred was
like because he's this Christian and
he's anti-paganism all this thing he
actually he actually removes all of the
Pagan remarks and and and uh all the
Pagan references and things like that of
boethius and when people say this I just
I always assume they have not actually
read it because Alfred does not
remove the references to paganism
although he changes them sometimes to
make them make more sense to his
audience but he actually uh
significantly enlarges them so for
instance there's a very brief reference
and this is actually all connected I
swear there's a brief reference in
boethius you know when it's was talking
about you know hubris and people who
thought they were doing great and then
and then turned out you know things
change for them right which is one of
the main focuses of the consolation
right so he as example he lists the the
titans of old right well Alfred says
now some people here might refer an
example to the titans of myth but you
and I know perfectly well that the
titans of myth are actually the Giants
of Genesis and he goes into this whole
long thing about ramrod and how Nimrod
was a giant and all this stuff so like
he he keeps the reference but he he
he's not christianizing it in the sense
of like sanitizing it he's just saying
ah but if you really knew about Genesis
and the anglo-sactions were obsessed
with Genesis and exodus specifically
um if you really knew about Genesis and
you knew about this other literature
these other stories you would know that
the titans of myth are actually the
Giants of Genesis chapter six yeah he's
doing Universal history he's doing
Universal history connecting things
together exactly
so one of the things they do is they
take this Germanic figure of Sheaf and
they connect him to this tradition of
the fourth son of Noah and then the
question sort of becomes was he born on
the ark was he born after he got off the
ark the ankle attacks and Chronicle
actually says he was born on the ark
um and uh they do this because it allows
them to connect
their lineage so one of the earliest
places that we see this being done in
writing is uh in the Anglo-Saxon
Chronicle there is a genealogy of
Alfred's father
and in the genealogy of Alfred's Father
which I have
I have right here so his father atha
wolf
Great Name by the way anybody out there
looking to name a son have a wolf very
strong name
um
um
uh I always threatened to do something
like that every time we we have a kid
yeah I used to do that too to my wife
and he would just drive me crazy uh see
see my wife uh my wife would call my
bluff on this so I have to be careful
but I like to do this to like like just
like give my parents to worry a little
bit but
um
yeah so uh so they trace his genealogy
all the way back and they get to these
characters and if you go look at the
early uh lineage that you find in the
the prologue to Beowulf you'll find a
very similar lineage it's not exactly
the same but is same names uh Bao the
son of sheldua sheldua of hero mode of
itermon
of Chef that is the son of Noah who was
born on Noah's Ark and then it traces
Noah's lineage back to Christ so
basically Alfred sets himself up as a
descendant though right so this is
really this is really important because
uh the kings of Wessex already knew uh
that and we'll we'll talk later about
how eventually these two threads come
together but the descendants of the the
kings of Wessex already knew that they
were descended from ovin
times they would have called them right
um every everybody knew this
so Alfred's project a big part of
Alfred's project and of course you have
to think you know he's got a bunch of
pagan Danes
right over there
and they're doing their own things and
of course they he did kind of make them
convert to Christianity but it took a
little while for that to take let's say
yeah two centuries that's it yeah yeah a
couple of centuries but um but you've
got a bunch of Danes right over there
and uh so like uh Germanic paganism is
present right and so Alfred's lineage
that you find here
um let's say it's a little quieter on
the Odin Parts yeah you know but the
thing that he's looking to do is really
traces traces lineage back to Noah and
of course ultimately back to Christ or
so back to Adam so he says well and
Christ because he it says you know who's
born on Noah's Ark who's the son of
lasnick the set of Methuselah the son of
Enoch the son of Jared the son of
Malachi the son of Canaan the son of
Enos the son of Seth the son of Adam the
first man and our father that is Christ
amen so uh and this is I mean that's a
deliberate reference back to The Gospel
according to St Luke right so you've got
that genealogy in The Gospel According
to Saint Luke and it goes all the way
back to the son of Adam who was the son
of God right yeah and the point of the
genealogy in St Luke's gospel you could
say compared to the genealogy that we
have in Matthew right Matthew is
sometimes too big a deal is made about
this but essentially Matthew's you know
Matthew is showing Christ's revealing
Christ as the Jewish Messiah but Luke
who's writing a gospel sort of for the
Greeks maybe
um or at least for you know the Hellenic
Jews Hellenic Believers he traces Christ
lineage all the way back to Adam because
the point is to show
that Christ didn't just come to save
did you the Jews yeah you can't just
right he came to save everyone and that
he sort of
um by uh that that you know by this
recapitulation he becomes the new Adam
he becomes the new head and then
everyone is gathered back under him
again
this genealogy is deliberately echoing
that right it's deliberately echoing
this to show
uh where do the Anglo-Saxons fit
in sort of the vast scheme of everything
and ultimately
where do they fit in the story of
Redemption where did they fit in
Christian household and what's really
weird
is that they go this route because
literally everyone else if you look at
Welsh Chronicles if you look at French
Chronicles if you look at German
Chronicles on the continent literally
everyone else uh just traces themselves
back to japheth which is what many
European would do in the Middle Ages
but the Anglo-Saxons and then ultimately
following them the Scandinavians once
they convert they they're not converted
they haven't converted at this point
um but they they convert and when they
convert they basically learn
Christianity from the English accents so
everyone else at this time just traces
their lineage back to japheth but for
the Anglo-Saxons it's really important
to trace themselves back to this fourth
son of Noah
um very self-consciously so and they do
it without
um I mean they change his name like you
can't get uh from you know uh uh yonton
to Chief like yeah you can't do it it
doesn't work they change his name they
um they ignore basically all of the uh
the things that uh you'd find in like
Eastern Traditions about him you know as
far as uh you know there's no
association with Nimrod here um Alfred
actually really how do I say this the
northern Germanic people they had their
own memory right they had their own
memory of of the war of god with with
the Giants this is one of the major uh
uh background pieces of the Beowulf poem
right is this it's one of the major
things that everybody kind of remembers
happened and of course it's because they
had it in their own midst and legends
and then Christianity came along
Christianity had it too so
here's where I will say something really
cool and then we'll just save it for
next time uh to explain there is every
reason to believe that the Beowulf poet
had access to the Book of Enoch who at
least had access to strong enochian
Traditions
um in fact
I'll just I'll just like to say this
wildly and like befuddle everyone
including my fellow English accents
there is a very strong case to be made
that Grendel's name actually comes at
least part of Grendel's name comes from
The Book of Enoch so I'll just throw
that one out there and let people like
percolate on it actually if you're not
an English accent that may not be a very
big deal to you but if I am you're gonna
be if you are you're gonna be like what
the heck did he just say so uh I'll
defend I'm not an anglo-saxonist and I
definitely want to hear yeah this yes I
would definitely want to hear how this
connects together because I can kind of
see it yeah and kind of see it but I
don't I think I think that next time
what we will have to do is actually just
spend the entire video on on the Beowulf
poem I think that's great because I've
had to do I've had an intuition for
years because I was always presented
Beowulf as a pagan story with a
Christian veneer no and when I read it I
thought anybody who knows kind of the
the Deep mythological stories that are
part of the Christian
tradition would not be able to say
anything like that no no no no there's
definitely uh paganism in there but it's
it's such a perfect weaving together of
things that it's almost impossible to
disentangle it but I really honestly I
believe that if you want to there are
certain there are certain texts certain
stories that are that are like the
Rosetta Stone you know where you come
across something that's untranslatable
uh but then here's here here's the same
text in a language you do know right
Beowulf is the Rosetta Stone for all of
this stuff
it's where especially in the in the old
North all of the stuff comes together in
the Beowulf poem and if you dig around
very closely I'll just throw out kind of
one little example right
um when Shield shaving you know he comes
uh he's shown washing up on the shore of
the Danish uh coast and the Danes take
him in they make him King
after
um after he dies they hold a big funeral
for him there are uh three funerals in
Beowulf one at the beginning one in the
middle one at the end very important to
the story but they hold this big uh
funeral for bail uh for for shield
shaving and when they do they give him a
ship burial but it's not like the one in
the movie where they push the ship out
and like shoot the arrow or whatever
they put him back in the ship they laid
uh they put a bunch of treasure on the
ship with him
and then they push the
ship out into the sea
and what it says is they sent him back
to those who had sent him
not and and earlier on
uh they keep saying that God sent him to
the Danish people God sent him to the
Danish people it was because they were
they'd had a bad King before and then
now they don't have a king at all and so
God sent him God sent him God sent him
but when they push the ship out it says
sent him back to those plural who had
sent them so the question is who sent
Shield shaving to the Danish people in
the Beowulf poem
um if you've uh if you've got this kind
of weird 19th century German version of
Christianity right where it's so
originally monotheistic that you don't
even have room to think about like the
Saints the Divine counsel Angelic orders
these different things then that just it
doesn't make any sense and you'd have to
and so they would look at that and they
would say aha Christianity doesn't have
them yeah
and so that's got to be the piece of
paganism that's got to be like like the
poet was just in cautious but actually
the Beowulf poet is I think one of the
most cautious writers who's ever lived
in terms of
I mean he's very artistic and the idea
that he would just make a a mistake like
that is I think
utter nonsense
um much it's a much better case to say
that well actually
this probably 8th Century monk there's a
little bit of uh
there's a little there's a lot of debate
actually about the dating of the Beowulf
uh poem The manuscript that we have
isn't the original it's a copy it's from
much later than what it was composed so
there's kind of this argument about when
was it composed and when I say there's
an argument there's a very there was a
very famous con uh a Conference held in
Toronto the University of Toronto called
the dating of Beowulf and an actual fist
fight I've talked to people who were
there an actual fist fight broke out at
the conference over this stuff oh my
goodness so so it's it's it's it's hotly
controversial uh but Academia like
scholarship is so originally there was
like an early date maybe like say age of
bead ascribed to it and then uh then
everybody's like you know it's a later
date and now Academia is actually coming
back around uh based on uh based on our
better understanding of like certain
metrical laws in Anglo-Saxon literature
and things like this the consensus is
kind of swinging back towards that
earlier date again anyway I'm an early
date of Beowulf guy if you're not I
don't care but um
anyway all right all this to say all
this to say you can come uh you can come
fight me
um you know it's fine you know I'm not
yeah I think with your Jujitsu we're
gonna avoid We're Not Gonna We're not
gonna fight you but um no but in all
seriousness uh so this this monk you
know probably probably so anyway I think
Bill was most likely written by an 8th
Century monk living in England yeah but
you you have given me like such a gift
in this discussion I'll be honest with
you like I hope so I've been looking
like I've been rambling no I've been
looking for years to find some hook at
the intuition that I have about this
notion of intermediary beings and that
in some ways you know the fact that we
could see fairies appear in in Great
Britain and you know that there was this
whole structure there and I thought how
do they account for that because it does
look like the notion of the gender these
these neutral or or ambiguous figures at
least that can sometimes be tricky
because they can go either way like it's
not that they they can be neutral they
can go either way and so this is great
that they actually have this actual
tradition and I think that I mean this
people will wonder why does Jonathan
care so much about this and the reason
why I care so much about this is that if
we talk about the notion that they are
principalities or they're they're like
there are agencies which are above the
human consciousness or that gather human
consciousnesses together and gather
phenomena together let's say then the
idea that it's only either
from heaven or hell that it's only good
or bad is not the one we experience we
experience Agency on us that doesn't
necessarily have those two polarities
and so the problem is
if we experience that then how do we
account for it in in in our own symbolic
structure how can we talk about it both
in technical terms that's easier but to
talk about it with a more mythological
language I found harder to do because
it's tricky and I see like I've I saw
C.S Lewis obviously playing around with
this you see you see you see people
playing around with this notion but not
not explicating it in a way that I found
uh like uh gratifying Saint Isaac to
Syrian explains all of it so uh there
you go he explains he explains what
exactly about exactly what you're saying
exactly what you're saying yeah see this
stuff is insane Isaac the Syrian he
talks about
talks about like the old gods and
obviously he doesn't use the word
fairies but
uh one of his homilies he talks about
this idea this and this idea that
um for him it's there's like a
there is a limit that is placed on how
much certain principalities and powers
are allowed to lie something like that
um and so so yeah so he's he's uh he's
got some really interesting stuff on
this I will see if I can dig that homily
up and send you yeah I would love to see
that I'll have to go back and see which
one it is but
um but yeah so so this is this stuff uh
maybe to kind of wrap it up here because
I think we're getting close to the time
that we we like to do these but
um so to kind of sum all this up
the Anglo the Anglo-Saxon Christians
made very free use
of the
biblical pseudo-epigrapha and of the or
you know what what you know you could
call the Apocrypha
um as well as Syrian Traditions right
they had access to these very important
early works of universal history and so
when they attempt to write their own
works of universal history which is by
the way that's what the Anglo-Saxon
Chronicle is people only study it now
for like you know you know Wars and
things like this but you know the
Anglo-Saxon Chronicle starts at you know
starts with creation yeah right
um
um it's you know it starts with uh or at
least it starts it starts back at uh it
doesn't start with creation it starts
with um the birth of Christ right but
it's I mean think about that decision
alone to say we're the we're the English
people not not British we're we're the
English people
and we're going to start our history
this is our Chronicle at the history of
the English people starts with
before the Incarnation of Christ 60
years guys Julius the emperor the first
of the Romans taught the land of Britain
and crushed the britons in battle and
overcame them nevertheless he was unable
to gain any Empire there and then
Octavius Reign 56 winners and in the
42nd year of his Reign Christ was born
that's the opening kind of the opening
entry more or less in the English accent
Chronicles so there so it's a work of
universal history because what they're
saying is our history actually begins
with the birth of Christ
and it begins with Rome yeah so what I'd
like to talk about next time is why
don't we just zoom in on Beowulf oh yeah
let's do that that'd be great and I'm
looking forward to that for sure I
actually have some well we'll do an
episode on Beowulf and I have some other
crazy ideas that I came up with today
regarding Beowulf and the symbolic world
so we'll talk about that later and maybe
uh maybe see what you think about that
and see what everybody else thinks about
it but um and then uh after that what
I'd like to do is kind of pick up again
after Beowulf and look at
um so there are three things so we said
before in uh Universal history that the
universal history project is really you
have to tie yourself back to Noah right
your or the the Old Testament you have
to tie yourself back to the Christian
story and then you also tie yourself
back to the Roman story right
well the north Germanic pagans as they
convert they are going to do a third
thing right which is try to tie
themselves back to Noah try themselves
back to Rome
and then tie themselves back to
all of their own like God's Heroes
ancestors and try to figure out where
did they fit in the story so yeah
because for their Traditions were in
some way so strong and their memory of
Their Own Story was so strong you know
the the the britons
the Gaelic people had lost a lot of
their spiritual leadership anyways when
by the time like Julius Caesar bragged
about how many Druids he slaughtered
like by the time that they convert to
Christianity I don't know how much was
left even of their own tradition whereas
the the northern people had this very
strong memory of their their own
Chronicles and and uh a big part of it
was just the fact that they converted so
late yeah yeah
but I think I think that'll be uh then
the next couple of videos is we'll just
really dive deep into the stuff because
it's great I can talk about it for hours
but also like there's so much it's very
difficult to kind of know where to start
so I hope this was too scattered for
people but maybe if there's at least
enough here to get people excited so if
you want to know is Grendel in The Book
of Enoch come back next time
all right all right Richard so uh thanks
everybody I think we're gonna try to get
back on track and have uh yeah have
these regularly again and uh Richard
showed you his book look up all the
projects the links will be in the
description there's a lot of interesting
things coming in the future you know in
all our collaborations so thanks Richard
for everything you do yeah thanks
Jonathan